so we're going to work on that uh
spiraling fighting geometry okay so uh
but just in key points
and he's going to come back at me all
right I'm going to go this way to turn
so from front inward position
boom
outward
s
cool
[Music]
foreign
in response
okay now I'm going to do that same
cookie hole
but I'm moving
this one goes this yeah every so
slightly goes out
so I moved
around
[Applause]
ever since like
but backwards
[Music]
you're doing big movements oh
big movements
do you think
but you gotta move on the spider but
foreign
there's one spiral go
and then you came into the uh shikaku in
the back and basically you're just going
to accelerate her backwards go ahead
do you see
so that's not the pattern I did but we
kind of do that pattern but not like
that okay so show you
hello
what that maneuver does because you're
going to change the spiral Direction uh
we got one more turn to do okay so I'll
show you boom boom are you doing here
you go assistant
the same size so you can see the
difference
Parts dreaming
okay same size so you can see all right
this way I'm gonna use his head on the
iPhone
[Music]
I can do it
you see how I still spiral okay
since she brought it up try both exactly
this time I'll go this way and he comes
last man again he's coming into me
always into me
a long time
it could be with one leg
to do
did you don't take one
[Music]
Cheeto can come
or any mechanics
okay spiral energy geometry let's
foreign
[Music]
you feel how he jammed your elbow hand
is if you pay attention
thank you
so there is a place
the elbow hand can be light
I'm not picking you up
I'm just checking you
checking it
don't worry okay
foreign